hello everyone today we are going to be
talking about earth's place in space
so for as long as there have been humans
we've been looking up at the stars and
wondering about our place in the
universe
our understanding about this has
improved over time and we have developed
models that can help us understand
something as fast as space
now models are just a way of
representing a system of ideas that help
us identify and understand patterns that
we see
models are a tool that can explain and
predict what we see in the world and
space around us and as we gain new
information we can update our models
so what kind of model might we construct
about how earth interacts with other
bodies in the universe
to begin with every day we can see the
sun rise in the east and set in the west
and other objects in the sky follow a
similar pattern
it was logical then for early models to
consider the earth as a stationary
object around which all of the universe
revolves
this is called a geocentric model geo
for earth and centric for center
and this geocentric model was quite good
at explaining a lot of the things that
we see in the sky like the apparent
motion of the sun and the stars
but there were issues with this
geocentric model
for example the motions of other planets
in the sky a planet like jupiter might
sometimes move backwards in the opposite
direction which isn't really very well
explained by this geocentric model
now when a model doesn't match our
observations like this we can add new
pieces to improve the model so
astronomers working with the geocentric
model did this by adding smaller cycles
within the planet's orbits around the
earth
adding these cycles did help match the
geocentric model to the observations but
there were many of these cycles required
and there wasn't a good explanation for
why these cycles existed and there
wasn't very much reasoning for them and
it made the model very complicated and
not particularly useful
let's pause and talk a little bit about
motion specifically apparent versus
actual
imagine you're sitting in a car and
driving through a forest to your
perspective as you look out the window
the trees seem to be whizzing by
but trees of course are rooted to the
ground it's actually you that are moving
relative to the surface of the earth
this is the difference between apparent
and actual motion
so back to our geocentric model
another way to explain some of the
issues with a model like the geocentric
model besides adding ever more
complicated features to it is to in fact
just come up with a new model
and this is what astronomers did the new
model that was proposed to replace the
geocentric model was the heliocentric
model
in this model the earth and all the
other planets actually revolve around
the sun helio means sun
this heliocentric model didn't need
complicated and unexplained cycles to
explain the way the other planets moved
across the sky it was an expected
outcome of the planet's orbits
now you may be wondering in this model
the sun is stationary so why does it
seem to be moving across the earth's sky
each day this is actually also easily
explained because the motion of the sun
in the sky is not actual motion it is
apparent motion
not only is the earth revolving around
the sun revolving means orbiting but the
earth is also spinning on its own axis
and so as the surface of the earth moves
with its spinning motion it makes it
appear as if the sun is moving across
the sky the spinning of the earth
actually explains why celestial objects
appear to rise and set over the course
of a day while the revolution or orbit
around the sun explains the motion of
those objects over the course of a year
it's important to remember that while
the heliocentric model does a better job
of explaining and predicting our solar
system which is what we want models to
do it is still a model and not a perfect
recreation of reality
for example while the heliocentric model
considers the sun as stationary we know
now that the sun is actually just one
star of many billions orbiting the
center of our own galaxy and so the sun
along with the rest of the solar system
is in fact moving
to summarize in this video we talked
about how we can use models to help us
understand what we see in the sky and
earth's place in space
as we learn more we improve our models
and we can develop new ones that do a
better job of explaining our
observations and predicting the world
around us such as the change from a
geocentric model to a heliocentric model
the earth then is a planet that orbits
the sun like the other planets of the
solar system and the sun appears to move
across the sky because the earth spins
on its axis
thanks for watching and i hope you
learned a little bit of something